[Music]
we have a Franks and be a true Franks
and beans Florida up for the first time
in a week or two Florida was a little
quiet cuz everyone's on ventilators down
there but we do with the Franks and
beans Florida coming out of Florida
politician is claiming beyonce is
italian pretending to be
african-american so yeah your florida
politician by the way what's up brother
i'm running for local office believed
ångström telasi I mean Florida's open
come get your [ __ ] frozen margaritas
half-price bring the whole family down
we got a half price
tattoos [ __ ] by a gator if you want
also [ __ ] Beyonce definitely if y'all
say that's an Italian woman it's sad we
won't go back to the thing her real name
the Florida politician is claiming
Beyonce's actual real name is Ann Marie
lost Rossi I believe um he's saying that
and he's put up a picture but you just
broke showed up real quick a Beyonce in
this Italian woman who look exactly
alike
in his opinion which I mean I don't see
it I mean the woman on the right looks
like a bad baby
Beyonce looks like Beyonce yeah I mean
this Florida you just never disappoint
you never disappoint you're [ __ ]
stupid
I'll bet ya it's what it is cuz that
doesn't look like Beyonce at all but
it's Florida and you just kind of got it
understand my dad Barney Rubble has
officially moved to Florida so that's
what is when you're when your dad was
too far do you think they'll give him an
honorary PhD yeah I don't have to they
have yet so I mean and also the rest of
the story is that he's part of the deep
stay and George cuz whatever conspiracy
comes from the right
make no mistake you're gonna have a
little George Soros in there I mean it
is a magical Jew to the right way George
Soros said that people love them guess
what Apple has caught tik-tok secretly
spying on millions of iPhone users and
guess what baby tik-tok made in China
yeah well China that Apple did a
security update and found out that tick
tock was spying on all its users
gathering information
and I deleted my tech-talk this morning
you did really I did yeah I'm in China
China cousin it's it's real it should be
really obvious to everyone that China
and Russia are ahead of us in waging
psychological warfare on the digital
sphere in the digital sphere and they're
tearing our country apart with fake
accounts and BOTS they're gathering
information on us
wars cannot be fought with weapons
anymore because of mutually assured
destruction so they are [ __ ] us up by
giving us mine viruses and now actually
maybe biological viruses and so yeah
[ __ ] tick-tock
It's Made buddy the [ __ ] Chinese
government has a hand in it they're
collecting our information I'm [ __ ]
out I wasn't doing any [ __ ] karaoke
videos endless yeah it's what it is is
blackout day hashtag black out day 2020
so one day of solidarity in the United
States where black people all people of
color do not spend a dollar today so
unfortunately we were gonna order the
equipment that we needed for the podcast
but vanity a control set so we're gonna
have to wait till tomorrow cuz she will
not order damn thing tonight
I just thought blackout Tuesday's was
the day that Betty I went out to drink
some wines with her black friends
yeah I just thought blackout Tuesday was
anytime father bill called me into the
rectory cafe gasolina
don't dangle butcher guys you better get
me my coffee yeah can I get my glasses
fall in ice I got yet oh um yeah my
family's into my family's now entered
the chat so yeah what can you do oh
you're you're just a gringo to your
family great yeah yep that's just we had
a thing where yep and we're back guys
let's do what what's
like in Bay Ridge right now whether it's
a hailstorm or with the chance to be
drive-by sometimes cuz you're just
sitting there and having a good time and
you get a sip onto the laptop yeah I was
but I quit my key clip it yeah it looks
like it's ready with a can supplying
Cinnabons cuz did you see did you see me
go down did you see nobody coming either
yeah let's get let's get to the [ __ ]
next story
Oh nudes hear some new nice needs to
think about America saying America is
gonna start to pay its gonna have to
wear masks for several years to come so
it's just what it is
get ready I'm sure there are going to be
people I you know how poverty got his
hairline tattooed on his head there's
gonna be people who are getting masks
tattooed on their faces they're gonna
get people are gonna get their mass
surgically attached to their face that's
going to happen I guarantee it's gonna
be like
[Music]